- So, okay please don't
put a dick in my face.
- Okay, it's not a dick,
it's a dildo.
- It's a dick.
Oh it's a dildo.
- Bald vaginas are insane.
No more bald vaginas and penises.
- Hey guys!
My name is Kate Siegel,
and this is Kim Friedman,
known on Instagram as
the Crazy Jewish Mom.
Our Instagram followers are
constantly asking for my mom's
sex advice and relationship questions,
so we're going to answer
a few of those right now.
What do you think is the most
important advice you can give
to a teenager who is
thinking about having sex?
- One, men think with their penises.
Second piece of advice is get tested,
and get tested together.
You have some wine, you get tested,
then you have sex.
- Nope, they're teenagers,
so no wine.
- No wine, no wine.
- No wine if you're teenagers.
Is it true that a man won't buy the cow
if he gets the milk for free?
- You go out for a
while, you have good sex,
it's really hot, it's really
fabulous, you know each other.
Make a decision, don't waste time, go.
Both ways, if you're
getting the milk for free,
if he's getting the milk for free,
- All the milk is free.
- Yeah, there's no commitment.
- Hot tips for first time pegging, tops.
- So pegging is when you take,
- You strap on a dildo.
- You take a dildo, and you put it on,
- Oh, we're using me as a model.
- Can you see this?
And you can add like a cute
little negligee onto it,
a little bra or something, make it sexy.
The strap on ...
- Ooh, it's vibrating.
What is your worst sex
experience that you ever had?
- I had this fantasy
that I wanted to have sex in Central Park.
We kinda like hid in the bushes.
We realized that we
were lying in dog poop.
- Ugh!
- Yeah.
- Blowjobs after marriage.
Oh god.
- You know what, in a relationship,
there's a lot of give and take,
so I would say, yes,
blowjobs after marriage.
- It's a generous act.
Have you ever faked it?
- Yeah, duh.
- We're going to do a speed round now
of questions from Instagram.
Spit or swallow?
- Spit, spit spit.
- Top or bottom?
- Bottom.
- Anal or no anal?
- No anal.
- Sex toys or no sex toys?
- Sex toys, yes.
- Sex on the first date, yes or no?
- No, never.
- Kissing on the first date, yes or no?
- Yes.
- How long should you be in a relationship
before you decide to get married?
- Six months.
- What's your favorite sex toy?
- Pegging.
No, that's not a sex toy.
- My mother has so kindly
volunteered to explain to me
how these lovely sex toys
provided by Buzzfeed work.
- Yes.
- Your dildo, you're gonna
make sure it's this side up.
- That's not going to work.
- You go down like this.
- You go down?
- And voila.
- Oh, this is fabulous.
- It's fabulous.
- You turn it on.
It's a vibrator, and you know
what else you can use this for?
I have a bad back sometimes,
so I'm gonna take this...
- No, no, no.
- Anal beads!
Do you know where your anus is?
- Yes, I know where my anus is.
- You put them in and
then you go like that.
- No, no, no.
- You don't even know what it's for.
- I know what it's called.
- Because I told you
right before we came on.
- It's a, a, a cock ring.
- It starts soft.
What are they?
- These are kegel balls.
- We wanna keep the vagina tight.
And this is the way you
keep the vagina tight.
On the anal beads, on the penises.
- No mom do not!
Mom, mom, mom, mom.
- It's fabulous moisturizer.
- Could you not?
- I hope we really educated you.
You know what?
Ladies...
- Lube your face.
- Do it, as long as you got tested first.
- And, you're using birth control.
- Absolutely.
All you do is you slap
it down on the desk.